dans quelques années quand vous
traverserez la banlieue parisienne
s'étant d'hélicoptères sans doute que
vous irez est partout vous survolerez
des villes dans le genre de celle ci on
les appelle les grands ensembles on les
appelle aussi les villes dortoirs
elles doivent permettre aux familles de
vivre loin de l'agitation et de l'air
malsain des grandes cités
elle existe dans le monde entier les
urbanistes et les sociologues leur
consacre des volumes et des congrès
des grands ensembles il y en a plusieurs
en france celui ci est à quelques
minutes de la capitale
sarcelles à 15 km de paris sur la route
damien un grand ensemble qui prévoit la
réalisation finale de dix mille
logements
on est à peu près à la moitié de
l'opération les arbres voyez-vous sont
encore tout jeune à quelques centaines
de mètres sarcelles le vieux un village
traditionnel plutôt fatigué qui a vu
naître une ville nouvelle dont il ne
sera bientôt plus qu'une dépendance
monsieur le maire je crois qu'on peut
dire que vous êtes un aventurier
vous êtes un aventurier votre commune
est une histoire étonnante une grande
aventure qui a commencé en quelle année
à l'époque il y avait à sarcelles
combien d'habitants il y avait sur
celle-ci 1500 habitants
actuellement vous en avez combien
actuellement nous sommes à peu près à
32000 le dernier recensement et de 29
mille huit cents et vous pensez que
quand sarcelles sera terminé on aura
combien d'habitants pensons que les
programmes en cours nous amèneront à 70
milles dans dix ans voici donc une ville
toute neuve en train de naître tout neuf
à l'exception d'un petit îlot que vous
allez découvrir des maisons qui étaient
noyés dans la plaine autrefois et qui
sont maintenant noyé dans l'ensemble des
bâtiments un petit bistrot le seul qui
existe dans le coin
patron vous êtes là depuis longtemps je
suis ici depuis trente-sept monsieur et
comment c'était en 37 en 37 sérieux des
champs d toujours des choux des
betteraves rouges et ensuite fitch et
aida grosse culture maraîchère ce qu on
appelait ça il y avait quelques maisons
quand même pas beaucoup 25 ans environ
et qui était habité par des gens qui
faisait quoi les riverains qui venaient
ici d'y monter leur petite cabane aux
mêmes d'autres qu'ils ont monté rendu un
arrêt qui sont restés comme moi et vous
aviez dit non il n'y a pas énormément de
monde chez vous pas tellement porte
comprends pas comment on peut croire
mais c'est comme ça tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours dans face
départ comme on pourrait bien le croire
mais qu'est ce qui se passe les gens
doivent penser à celle c'est à dire
qu'ils sont pas bien riches les loyers
sont trop chers
je pense que c'est ça puis on fait ça
comme un jeu maudit sont arrivés ici les
gens avec pas beaucoup de meubles il
faut meubler les pièces et puis où
habitaient avant que certains pèse
seulement qu'elle sait pas durable est
fait sur nés six enfants toute façon il
n'ya pas grand chose pour mettre tes
meubles
le prix des loyers c'est le principal
souci des habitants un ensemble cuisine
salle de bains deux chambres et salle de
séjour formant deux pièces 64 mètre
carré coûte 18 mille francs par mois
chauffage compris mais il faut déduire
de cela
l'allocation logement qui est souvent
importante le problème en fait dépasse
le cadre de sarcelles c'est un problème
général
les classes les moins favorisées de
notre société ont le plus besoin
d'appartements et c'est justement les
appartements neufs qui coûte le plus
cher
d'autant que le français par rapport aux
autres peuples est habitué à consacrer
un budget moins important à son logement
pour moi les loyers sont très chers
c'est ça qui qui nous en empêche de
vivre vraiment bien parce que moi je
paye 21 mille francs par mois ce qui
fait à retirer sur 110 millions ça fait
ça fait lourd 15600 en par mois
chauffage compris h coux le chômage est
en baisse toute l'année c'est à dire que
le logement que je l'occupé ce n'est pas
tellement spacieux il n'y a aucune porte
nous avons ali nouh qui est un esclavage
et l'entretenir et aucune porte entre la
cuisine la chambre la salle de séjour
je crois que je me ferai jamais un
logement pareil au point de vue ce n'est
pas un team du tout on ne peut pas avoir
un petit coin à soi pour lire pour être
tranquille les les bâtiments sont
terriblement sonore on vit avec le
voisin aussi bien au dessus ou en
dessous qu'à côté que le principal grief
que vous pouvez faire à la vie de farce
elle la promiscuité ne faut pas assez de
tri dans les catégories des gens c'est à
dire que vous estimez que les gens sont
trop loin trop mais oui oui trop mais
comme comme catégories sociales et vous
habitiez à quel endroit auparavant à
livry gargan
je trouve que la vie à sarcelles et
raismes à l'automne d'ailleurs
l'après-midi lorsque je me promène avec
ma petite fille
il est très rare que je rencontre
d'autres personnes ce qui me déplaît le
plus c'est certainement l'architecturé
niveau tous ces gros cube entassés les
uns à côté des autres
ça me fait peur c'est pas joli c'est pas
joli du tout je n'arrive pas à
m'habituer
tu es tellement habitué aux petites
maisons voyez-vous avec des cheminées
avec des volets quand on arrive ici aux
voix c'est ça vous effraie ça vous
écrase totalement tu pourrais jamais
voulu tuer chez crop
ces dames ont fait le résumé des griefs
les plus courants il y à aussi l'absence
de persiennes aux fenêtres on s'en
plaint souvent le goût du logis bien
clos bien isolé on le retrouve partout
dans ces familles derrière ses fenêtres
mais ce goût du logis bien close est une
tradition française on peut penser que
cette tradition a moins d'importance
tout de même que le fait d'être enfin
auch ou à l'aise à l'abri ici la plupart
des habitants viennent de logements
insalubres trop petit trop sombre trop
humide
tenez entré chez les ou d'un chaque jour
la mère reste seul le père travaille à
paris la fille aussi qui est secrétaire
et le fils qui suit des cours techniques
le petit frère et écoliers à sarcelles
michel dans l'appartement que vous
occupiez dans un paris commode et
organisez votre vie mais c'est à dire
que je n'avais pas de chambre et alors
je couchais avec mes deux frères dans la
salle à manger
alors le soir avant de s'endormir pour
pouvoir défaire les lits superposés il
fallait repousser la table poussé un
petit peu le buffet est peut-être sur le
divan alors c'était toute une
organisation et je couchais au rez de
chaussée du lisp reposer et mon frère
couchait au premier étage et gilbert
dans ce petit divan qui commençait à
devenir un petit peu trop petit monsieur
d'un quels sont à votre avis en résumé
les avantages et les inconvénients de la
vie à sarcelles les avantages d'abord on
a un logement plus grand
plus aéré plus lumineuse c'est l'avis
est plus saine
le
la nuit on dort mieux parce que il y a
moins de bruit que dans la musique dans
le pari les inconvénients genevois
uniquement que la question transports
questions de transport qui fait perdre
du temps pour aller travailler et pour
revenir du travail est tout de même le
transport grève votre budget parce que
la z3 aller à paris oui nous sommes 3es
à paris ça représente que ce qu'on avait
dit environ 7000 francs 7 à 8000 francs
par mois cette année 1000 francs par
mois qui augmentent le prix du loyer
évidemment les transports sont
indispensables ou petit matin sarcelles
se vident la gare pour l'instant voyez
vous ce n'est qu'une halte la sncf comme
les autres grandes administrations qui
ont eu à s'occuper de sarcelles a été
dépassé par la fièvre de croissance de
cette ville un jour prochain ce sera une
gare importante qui emmènera des
milliers d'habitants de sarcelles vers
paris tous les matins par la ligne du
nord en 14 minutes
[Applaudissements]
tenez retrouver la façade que nous avons
regardé tout à l'heure au point du jour
on prend conscience de ce que c'est une
ville dortoir
les hommes sont partis travailler et le
grand ensemble va vivre sa journée
uniquement avec des femmes et des
enfants
nous sommes ici dans un univers
domestique dans un ensemble de foyers
une ville sans usine sans bureau 100
ateliers sans fumée sans bruit sans
circulation
une ville réduite aux femmes et aux
enfants
la vie extérieure
la voilà dans les centres commerciaux
aucune boutique ne vient rompre l'
ordonnance des rues les centres
disposent et en des lieux choisis
permettent de trouver les vivres et les
objets indispensables
les principaux commerçants sont groupés
pour l'instant ces commerçants ils sont
débordés
la concurrence ne joue guère il faut que
d'autres centres s'ouvre de grands
magasins sortiront de terre en même
temps naîtront des piscines des stades
mais le principe restera lui même des
centres commerciaux sportifs ou
administratifs éloigné des groupes
d'immeubles
est ce le goût de tout le monde
sarcelles est une ville en train de
naître
il ne faut pas trop vite la juger et
d'ailleurs là bas depuis trois ans voyez
vous la vie s'organise sarcelles est un
chantier à un boom est déjà une ville à
l'autre et voilà quelques images d'un
dimanche les joueurs de boules les
promeneurs les amoureux ont pris le pli
on déambule sur le boulevard comme à
thionville ou à morlaix les enfants
s'ennuient le dimanche
les adolescents et les enfants forment
la majorité de la population de
sarcelles
ce sont les jeunes ménages qui ont
besoin de venir ici cependant que les
beaux quartiers voit s'éteindre leur
vieillards des enfants il en arrive tous
les jours il en est tous les jours
tenez combien y at il eu de baptême en
un an monsieur le curé 289 m
et combien d'enterrement trois
enterrements
vous avez bien entendu 289 baptême trois
si vous prenez tous les habitants de
sarcelles et vous fait la moyenne de
leur âge vous trouvez 12 ans alors que
la moyenne d'âge des français c'est de
36 ans vous entendez bien trois fois
plus et tous ces jeunes posent des
problèmes des problèmes d'école de
distraction d'éducation populaire les
sociologues vous le diront les grands
ensembles favorise la délinquance
juvénile pour l'instant à sarcelles il
n'y a guère de voyous et la maison des
jeunes y est pour beaucoup
ni politique ni confessionnelles elle
reçoit garçons et filles de 15 à 20
alors vous êtes ici à sarcelles depuis
combien de temps vous depuis décembre 58
avant vous habitiez paris quand vous
êtes arrivé à sarcelles la première
semaine vous avez vécu ici quelle
impression aux est ressenti la première
semaine
le sar oui le sahara y avait plein de
bouts de la neige partout des bâtiments
à moitié construit rien ni cinéma ni
juste ni martial qui est d'ailleurs été
à cet emplacement
c'est tout pas de copains et 1 alors je
sens d'être le jour à paris je ce moyen
pour retrouver mes anciens copains alors
qu'est-ce que vous alliez faire
appareils marc voir mes copains que je
veux comme je vous le disais autres
unités
tout ce que je faisais et là vous
faisiez quoi ensemble je veux qu'on
fasse tourner autour du square de la
marche entier vers d'autres à faire
aussi
paris c'est bien beau mais faut voir de
l'argent et l'argent quand on est jeune
on n'a pas beaucoup
et ici qu'est ce que vous faites
maintenant à sarcelles ben ici
je me promène avec mon copain dont on a
une grande avenue alors c'est pour se
promener on se promène entre copains on
discute pas toujours quelque chose à
faire est toujours un coeur pur une
commission accompagne la maison de
jeunes maintenant il y en a une je
suppose alors dites moi franchement est
ce que ça vous semble important qui est
cette maison des jeunes très important
d'y aller par la maison des jeunes entre
nous qu'est ce que vous ferez l'autre
camp se trouve en prison je conçois
cette moyenne d'âge de 12 ans elle est à
la fois le slogan est le problème de
sarcelles
ces enfants là vont vivre leurs jeunes
années dans le calme et le confort ils
sont loin des taudis certes mais du même
coup ils sont loin des leçons de choses
que suscite l'animation d'une ville ou
d'une campagne où l'on travaille quand
on leur demande de dessiner leur maison
on obtient l'ensemble géométriques qui
évoque un nom de nouveaux dont on aurait
tendance à se méfier
[Musique]
et si on leur demande de dessiner une
maison il reconstitue le petit toit la
fumée la barrière la route
traditionnelle mais de la regrettée les
bicoques lugubre et malsaine de la
banlieue parisienne
il y à un pas que je me refuse à
franchir
sarcelles commence à vivre la sortie des
écoles
le calme de l'après midi déjà les heures
de la journée marque le rythme de cette
vie nouvelle
les grands ensembles sont ils un mal
nécessaire ou un nouvel aspect du
plaisir de vivre ce sera si vous le
voulez bien à ces enfants de répondre
dans quelques années
[Musique]